in my high school days I didn't find the
physics that I was talk very interesting
I was I was better at mathematics and
chemistry amongst the scientific
subjects and I was quite enthusiastic
about chemistry understanding the
structure of matter at the molecular
level and gradually I came to know that
there were deeper levels and that these
these were classified as physics and
there was an interesting thing we're
interesting things to do in theoretical
physics there but one of the influences
on me which probably a former pupil at
the same school of about a quarter of a
century earlier Paul Dirac who was one
of the founding fathers of quantum
mechanics in the mid-1920s and I was
curious about what he'd done because his
name appeared frequently on the roll
call of the achievements of former
pupils I was curious and that came that
led me to to read about atomic physics
and quantum theory before I was ever
taught them well the only the only other
thing perhaps to add about the
influences in in my days at high school
was that at the end of my time there it
was very soon after the end of the war
and the dropping of the bombs on Japan
and I I went to some public lectures in
the University of Bristol organized by
the two professors of physics what ones
irritation and one experimentalist these
were lectures for the public to tell
them what what was the background of
these these the development of these
bombs and it is a great success
series of lectures and the experimental
physicist was sussel powell who worked
in experimental particle physics in
those days it involves sending packages
of photographic emulsion up into the
upper atmosphere with the help of
balloons and he decided to give some
lectures about his own work which I then
went to when I learned from him a lot
about the current state of experiment in
particle physics and that helped me to
see what I wanted to do